ça a des avantages qui sont très
importants je vais les résumer très
rapidement ça a des avantages pour les
éditeurs radios que nous sommes ça
répond à la problématique de saturation
de la bande passante il peut y avoir
plus de radio il peut y avoir aussi une
diffusion meilleure sur l'ensemble du
territoire ça aussi des avantages
indéniables pour les auditeurs ils ont
été très bien rappelés par le président
de la Rome sur l'absence de changement
de fréquence sur le fait que ça reste
gratuit sur aussi le fait que sur toutes
les données associées au programme sont
beaucoup plus visibles et encore
beaucoup de progrès d'ailleurs qui sont
permis par cette technologie là donc il
y a vraiment une amélioration de
l'attractivité du média radio et c'est
bien la raison pour laquelle les autres
pays européens ont adopté bien avant
nous cette technologie quand on regarde
la couverture du réseau dab plus dans
les autres pays autour de nous en Europe
beaucoup sont proches de 100%
le Danemark 99,9% la Norvège 99,7%. la
Suisse
99,5%. l'Allemagne la Grande-Bretagne la
Belgique l'Italie c'est pas que le nord
de l'Europe c'est sa descend aussi plus
vers la Méditerranée nous en France
voilà nous avons un retard qui a
commencé à être attrapé c'est bien c'est
important mais il faut aller plus loin
et ça passe évidemment par le fait de le
faire connaître aux français puisque
même si la couverture du réseau en train
de se déployer progressivement
nous avons encore que 14% des fois les
Français qui sont équipés ce qui veut
dire que il y a vraiment un enjeu
d'adoption de cette nouvelle technologie
et de savoir ce que le secteur veut
faire pour qu'elle s'adopte pour qu'elle
soit réellement adoptée